first of all just say your full name for
me linda
linda phillips and your daughter's name
my daughter was naturally christened but
we would have called her laura
my name is anne-marie daracot and
what was the name of your child she was
going to be called catherine
my daughter was still born in 1976
due to primitives she was born with the
top of her
brain missing and the top of her skull
missing
never saw her don't know what they did
with her
don't know where she's buried i never
saw the baby
i didn't know what was wrong with the
baby and she was taken away
anne and linda gave birth at a time when
deformed still-born babies were
sometimes whisked away from their
mothers
with few questions asked there's lots of
different children buried at 4-1-6
using public library records and
recently located her child's unmarked
grave
linda is still looking it would be nice
to have somewhere where i can go
sorry where i can put flowers
where i can put a teddy bear right now
there's nowhere
both women believe their children were
born with birth defects because of a
drug they took
while pregnant called primidos the
manufacturer shearing now owned by
bayer denies this but a year ago
an independent committee led by baroness
cumberlage said primidos
and other drugs caused avoidable harm
and the government apologized for
regulatory failings
the committee made nine recommendations
including that the government offer
financial redress
to victims of primitives vaginal mesh
and the epilepsy drug vaporate because
there were clear failures to properly
regulate the risks
but a year on the redress hasn't
happened
i think that some of the action has been
glacial it has taken so long to achieve
things
and these people have been waiting
for decades we've seen
some progress on the patient safety
commissioner we've now got it in law
which is really good but
what we are so so needing
is some redress for those that have
suffered
the drug valparate has been shown to
cause a range of birth defects but
unlike primitives
is still used today as an effective
epilepsy drug
collectively they have autism
adhd they say day incontinence
you know hypermobility
a lot of learning problems that they
need extra help with
leanne and warren matthews have three
children with severe problems caused by
vowel parade
medics had concerns about the drug
decades ago but campaigners say women
using valparai continue to get pregnant
unaware of the risks
only in the last week did the matthews
receive a letter from the nhs
warning about the drug they've known for
so long why has it taken this long for
the letter to come out
i mean just it just seems as if they're
doing bare minimal
every single step of the way
government's damaged our children
and they're just going whatever speed
they want to that's how it seems
there's no urgency that's how you feel
the government's done this to you
absolutely
there's no one else they was the one who
okay that medication
they knew the dangers they knew the
dangers 48 years ago
and they did nothing some lessons have
been learned
since linda and anne were pregnant but
not quickly enough
for warren and leanne's family and while
the government says it's working on
implementing five
of the recommendations from last year's
report it's still considering others
jason farrell sky news